All right. Today it's time to program a
another Nissan. Uh, currently we have a
2022 Nissan Maxima. So, I got a new
aftermarket fob here. Uh, actually, this
one might be a OEM refurb. I'm not
sure. I can't remember what I bought.
But, uh, anyway, we're going to be using
the IM 608. So, we're going to go into
the Nissan system. First of all, I'm
going tell you guys some things to to
watch for as you're programming it to
make sure everything goes smooth.
Nissan's are pretty basic. Um, there's
not a lot you have to do. The only thing
you really have to concern yourself with
is to remember that when you do
programming on Nissan, no matter what,
you always erase any keys that are in
the system and you add in new ones. Um,
so if a customer doesn't have all their
keys present, you have to let them know,
say, hey, any key that's not present
will not be added back into the system
and they will need to be reprogrammed.
Now, um, also you you don't really use a
used key, like you can reset them and
whatnot, but if it's an original key for
the car, then you can reuse a used one
as long as it's original for that car,
like it's been programmed to that car
before. Uh, so what was this? A
2022. But other than that, everything is
really straightforward. So, this is,
like I said, this is a OEM unlock, I
believe, because it's got the logo.
Um, this is
a repo car, so there's no need to worry
about any other
keys. All right, so this is saying to
open and close the door. I I don't never
do that, but I will turn on the hazards.
Basically, we just want to wake up the
BCM to make sure that, you know, it's
active and we can communicate with
it. And the flashers are good because I
believe they make the BCM stay awake.
So, like if you were to just hit the
start button, that also wakes up the
system, but it can go back to sleep
while you're trying to communicate. So,
we turn the hazards on just to keep the
system
awake. Sometimes if the battery is too
low, I'll actually cut those off. You
don't have to have them on for the
programming, but every once in a while,
you'll want to hit the start button just
to keep the system active if you do
that. Okay? And if if you look on the
screen, you'll see it says to place the
key near the start switch. That's
important because now we know that the
start switch is the sensing portion for
the proximity. So when we program it,
that's where we'll have to add it. Now
all Nissan are like that. That's nothing
nothing special for Nissan, but for
other cars, that can be very helpful,
especially some of the Kia where they
have different areas. It's like some
will have the button, some will have the
little area in a slot. So that that
information when you see it is very nice
to have. Okay. So we're going to go into
the remote. We're going to do smart key
learning. All this is
done. This says to click okay. And then
immediately hit the start button with
the key. And you don't have to use the
key to push it down. You just have to
have it close. But we'll we'll do we'll
do it that way just to be sure. Okay.
Okay. So, we're going to come over here
and do just like
that. And then it says to hold the
ignition down until the dash comes on,
which it did, which is good. That means
it unlocked the
steering the steering lock, which we
needed to do for
programming. Okay. So, it was good. So,
I'm going to hit
okay. And now, we're going to turn the
switch off. Okay. We see the dash cut
off. We come back here. We're going to
hit okay. So now it
says
that we have to hit the logo of the key
onto the button and wait. So what we're
going to do is we're going to hit
okay. All
right. Actually, it says just to It says
not to hit okay. Let's not hit okay.
Okay. So the first thing we want to do
here is we want to hit the button. And
you're going to see this start flashing.
Once that starts flashing, you take and
hold your key to it and it will read
your key and we'll see the dash come on.
Right? So, I'm hold the key away. You
see it flashing. Now, I'm going to hold
my key here and the dash should come
on. And if you notice there, we saw the
security light, which was right there,
flash five times. That's perfect for
Nissan's. That means that it was reading
the key and programming the body control
module with the key ID. Okay. So, now
we're going to cut the switch off. Let's
wait a little bit. Not too long. About
about 3 to 5 seconds. All right. And
then we're going to do it again. We're
going to push
it. We're going to
wait. Okay. And we see that it done it
again.
Same thing except we didn't see the
immobilizer light this time which is
perfect. That's what we want. Okay. So,
we'll go ahead and turn it off now. And
we see on the dash key registration
complete. So, at this point, you don't
even need to hit okay on your machine.
It's actually already done in the
system. And this is
just, you know, the system's own
message. Okay. And if you wanted to add
more keys, you could. I'm not going to.
I'm just going to hit next. And this is
all done. So, we can cut this off. So,
2022 Nissan Maxima
um OEM Refurb. I believe I got this from
American Key Supply. That's generally
where I get them from. Um I met the
owner a long long time ago and he was a
really nice guy. So, I just always kind
of stuck with them. I know a lot of
people have trouble, but uh I have never
had any issues with them. So, lock and
unlock is working.
Okay, let's make sure it starts
up. I'm reaching on the dash for the
button. Okay. Yeah, there we go. You see
the RPM gauge go
up and key number one
detected.
Perfect. Job done.